you know always talk about this when the
stock market goes down
but I never talked about when the stock
market goes up so I should take the
second and remind you have you ever
noticed that the news people all report
on the stock market only when it goes
down
[Music]
remember that's how the news report
sounds ever heard that did you ever hear
the news report where the stock market
went up 20%
you would have made 20% on your money if
it was invested last year the S&P 500
closed up nineteen point four percent
that means all of my mutual funds which
I'll perform the S&P I haven't gotten
the details in on mine yet but that
generally outperformed the S&P and they
have for 40 30 20 and 10-year track
records so I suppose last year they
outperform the S&P and so that means I
made over 20 percent on my money last
year did you hear anybody reporting that
did you hear ABC did your Good Morning
America do a whole special on the stock
market went up almost 20 percent last
year how long it's been since that
happened a long time went up almost 20
percent the Dow Jones is over 25,000
right now 25,000 those you know and this
just telling how biased the news media
is okay I'm not endorsing Donald Trump
but they're so scared that he might get
credit for something I'm not sure it's
due to him I wouldn't give him credit
for it but they're so scared that the
fact that the freaking economy is
booming
I mean unemployment rate is almost
nothing in most states right now in the
state of Tennessee our unemployment rate
is under 3% that means if you're
breathing at least twice a minute you
have a job
I mean it's nuts you know I mean there's
no way you know it's just it's
incredible and the Dow is over 25,000
and the stock market's up nineteen point
four percent last year the S&P four to
2017
so but I mean they're scared to death
that they're gonna give Trump credit for
that by just admitting that it actually
occurred and so have you heard any of
them reporting it CNN ABC NBC CBS even
Fox have you heard a single news report
about the booming stock market now I can
assure you of this that your entire
future would have ended the world would
have melted down and the world would
have come to an end had the stock market
dropped 20% they would have been leading
the news with it line that sounded like
a beagle chasing a rabbit every night it
would have sounded like a scalded dog
like somebody threw hot water on a dog
in the middle of a cold weather they
would have been whining and screaming
and flopping around and you ain't heard
one single report not one have you not
won you haven't heard a single report on
the news you haven't read it in your
local newspaper all now owned by canet
thank you very much some version of USA
Today in your hometown now if your
hometown newspaper website does not look
just like USA TODAY's website you have
it wet you have a newspaper that is not
owned by Gannett but there's very few of
them left an extreme left-wing yes
scared to death to say Trump did
anything right you bet and I'm not
accusing Trump of this he I'm not saying
he did this okay not at all I'm not
giving him credit either but they're so
afraid that there might be some
political capital to the economy booming
that they have done zero reporting on it
plus it's just a point to them to report
on anything that's positive if it bleeds
it leads baby the car wrecks the murders
the death of the American dream that's
what leads on the nightly news you're
not seen one of them you haven't seen a
single news article or report unless
you're reading some kind of geeky nerd
financial journals like I might read but
you haven't seen it anywhere else the
Dow Jones and I mean the S&P 500 closed
up almost 20% last year it's what you
made on your 401k by the way if you've
invested like we taught you to invest
good growth stock mutual funds growth
growth and income aggressive growth and
international that's what you made on
your money you just made that on your
money did anybody tell you know if you
open up your statement when you get it
you know you'll probably get it in March
and it'll reflect back on the closing
numbers 417 you're gonna see what
happened in 17 but now that you're
curious because I brought it up you can
jump online and probably have a little
app on your phone with the that comes
free with your phone with the stock
market stuff on it you just push the lap
and it'll pop up and show you what's
going on then push on the little S&P and
it'll give you the whole details it
didn't take me about about 30 seconds to
figure this out at the commercial break
I did detailed research for the show
today
not okay seriously nobody is reporting
on this I give you pause about what
you're allowing these people to come
into your living room and say to you
every night you're allowing them to form
some of your ideas and opinions with
what you read and what you watch and
they're so irresponsible and so scared
of political capital going one way or
the other to the left or the right that
they that they are so freakin biased and
they're biased against good news that
none of them have reported that some of
you made the most money you've ever made
in your entire working lives last year
on your 401 K if you are 40 years old
you had the best year in your working
lifetime last year in your 401 K and not
one news outlet told you that that ought
to scare you a little bit about the
stuff you're allowing into your living
room